[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le jeudi 17
janvier bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de
tv 60 18 26 minutes pour faire le tour
de l'actualité locale tout de suite les
titres après une année 2010 8 avec 1,5
pour cent de croissance économique
quelles sont les perspectives pour les
prochains mois des chefs d'entreprise du
département sont-ils optimiste ou
inquiets en ce début 2019 à quelles
difficultés font ils face nous poserons
ces questions à notre invité bertrand de
créer président du medef 78 de nouveaux
locaux pour yvelines numériques le
syndicat les a intégrés l'été dernier à
guyancourt l'inauguration officielle
s'est déroulée ce matin en présence de
plusieurs élus locaux yvelines
numériques est en charge notamment du
déploiement de la fibre optique sur tout
le territoire à l'horizon 2020 et puis
il était en poste à chambord avant
d'arriver dans la vallée de chevreuse
pascal thévard et depuis le 1er janvier
le directeur général du château de
dampierre en yvelines une grande mission
faire rayonner à nouveau cet édifice du
17 xviie siècle lieu de séjour royaux
pascal t bar sera sur ce plateau
nouveaux locaux donc pour yvelines
numériques le syndicat mixte ouvert
chargé de développer l'offre numérique
du département s'est installé à
guyancourt l'été dernier inauguration
officielle des lieux ce matin à leurs
reportages d'aurélie rond et de marylène
yapi chinois
dans sa politique de déploiement du
numérique le département des yvelines
ans et en 2016 evelyne numérique un
regroupement du département et des
intercommunalités en un syndicat mixte
ouvert chargé du développement des
plateformes numériques de service public
on travaille dans deux domaines
essentiellement le numérique pour
l'éducation et nous déployons donc des
outils au bénéfice des élèves dès que
des parents d'élèves et de l'ensemble de
la communauté éducative notamment les
enseignants et nous travaillons
également dans le domaine de la sûreté
électronique où nous développons une
plateforme innovante qui permet de faire
remonter en temps réel
un nombre d'image d'un très grand nombre
de sites un service de vidéo protection
déployée dans tous les collèges du
département des robots dans les hôpitaux
ou les domiciles pour maintenir le
contact entre l'école et les enfants de
nombreux projets en cours de
développement c'était important de
bénéficier de locaux qui permettent
justement tout ce développement et qui
permettent de se concentrer de
travailler en groupe de recevoir des
partenaires du conseil départemental de
versailles yvelines numériques a donc
déménagé à guyancourt dans ses nouveaux
locaux plus modernes et fonctionnels
pour remplir sa mission haut débit fin
2020 l'ensemble du haut débit sera
déployé dans la zone blanche du
département des yvelines de deux façons
soit par l'installation de la fibre
numérique choix parce qu'on appelle la
montée en débit c'est à dire qu on
équipe les réseaux téléphoniques
existants de systèmes qui permettent
d'augmenter leur puissance pour faire
passer plus d'image cette journée
d'inauguration est également marquée par
le lancement du nouveau site internet du
syndicat mixte ouvert
de nouveaux locaux toujours à vue en
cours la société apave a inauguré
récemment son agence à guyancourt en
espace décloisonné cette entreprise est
spécialisée dans l'accompagnement de ses
clients face aux risques techniques
humains et environnementaux sur son site
et guillon courtois apave espère
dépasser les 8 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires cette année après un
très bon et 2018 écouter ses interviews
au micro de nicolas landry
et bien déjà c'est l'effet des
cloisonnements historiquement en a
plusieurs métiers
donc et pour les responsables et pour
les collaborateurs ça permet d'améliorer
la commune la communication entre les
métiers historiquement l' agence de
saint quentin en yvelines est une agence
qui s'est développée régulièrement ces
dernières années sur l'ensemble de nos
métiers aujourd'hui on est une agence
qui passe à une centaine de
collaborateurs ça confirme effectivement
que nous on est bien l locomotive
économique de saint quentin en yvelines
et je suis ravi et d'accueillir cette
nouvelle entreprise sur les territoires
à guyancourt on a plus de 1200
entreprises de la très petite ce trop
grands comptes et c'est important de
pouvoir avoir effectivement des
entreprises de tous niveaux pour venir
s'installer on continue de parler
économie avec mon premier invité
bertrand de craie bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le président du medef yvelines le
mouvement des entreprises de france
alors l'année économique sera t-elle
bonne quelles sont les perspectives les
craintes aussi des chefs
d'entreprise du département juste avant
de vous laisser la parole je vous
propose d'écouter ses interviews le
président de promo paul lotman nasri a
présenté ses voeux c'était la semaine
dernière ses voeux à la pépinière aux
membres de cette pépinière elle est
implantée à montigny le bretonneux
nicolas landry a interrogé les
entrepreneurs présents sont-ils
optimiste pour 2019 écoutez
je perçois l'année 2019 avec beaucoup de
confiance je pense qu'aujourd'hui de par
la suite de 2018 nous avons beaucoup
silo en tout cas dans mon activité qui
le domaine de l'énergie
beaucoup de signaux de nouvelle affaire
de prise de conscience de l'ensemble
d'un écosystème alors quand je
d'écosystèmes les particuliers mais
surtout via les entreprises pour
développer de nouveaux projets très
performant sur lesquels on pourra
évidemment je l'espère contre pour ce
qui concerne mon entreprise oui je n'ai
aucun aucun problème je connais une
croissance d'environ 30% par an depuis
2011 sans sans discontinuer donc je n'ai
aucune inquiétude à se faire on a fait
une bonne année 2010 8 je suis plutôt
confiant sur l'année 2019 puisque le
digital et même l'organisation digital à
travers des sites les sites internet à
travers aussi aujourd'hui l'arrivée de
la fibre optique donc qui fait que
l'information se diffuse de plus en plus
rapidement font que
pour ma part en tout cas j'ai une grande
confiance sur 2019 avec déjà un
portefeuille de prospects qui sont
intéressés par une solution de
l'optimisme donc confiants mais en tout
cas par une dernière enquête auprès des
pme de bpi france le lab une majorité
reste relativement confiant sur les
perspectives d'activité cette année ce
que vous êtes sur la même longueur
d'onde bertrand de crise alors moi je
suis quand je vois des reportages et de
témoignages comme ça ça me rend heureux
évidemment et ça illustre bien que les
chefs d'entreprise sont des gens
optimistes sont des gens qui croient à
des projets sont des gens qui imaginent
l'avenir et ils ont besoin de cet
optimiste mais vous savez pour créer
optimisme et utopiste ou réaliste du
coup dirais que nous sommes on voit
toujours le verre à moitié plein plutôt
que le verre à moitié vide voilà donc
c'est pas optimiste oui positif mais
nous avons besoin de stabilité là on
donne stabilité parce que quand on crée
une entreprise ou coûteux la développe
on a des projets il faut investir il
faut après ça c'est pas sûr annoncé sur
plusieurs années il faut embaucher quand
on embauche et bien c'est aussi sur
pluzz année ou alors on fait du temps
partiel et tout ce qu'on ne veut pas
faire ou du goût du temps
pour dire tu es condamné cdd si vous
voulez embaucher du personnel et des
fois garder le conserver dans du travail
y avoir de la lisibilité alors moi j'ai
des craintes des inquiétudes des
inquiétudes mais
je dois les avoir
elle exhale actuelle peut être le
mouvement des gilet jaune qui a priori
aurait freiné la croissance 1,5 pour
cent de croissance revu par l'insee ils
tablaient sûr sur 1,7 en octobre ça a
freiné l'activité économique s'est
reprise et gilets jaunes ripoux de
raisons pour deux raisons d'abord ça
gênait tous les trafics ça a perturbé ça
a perturbé dans l'activité que j'ai le
jeu que j'aime ans on a eu des camions
qui ne venaient pas qu'il marchait pas
donc effectivement un vrai frein à
l'économie dans des régions comme paris
bien il ya eu des magasins fermés dès
resteront fermés des musées reflétant la
chute étaient drastiques
donc effectivement le gilet jaune et en
plus le signal envoyé par le gilet jaune
quelle sera la suite parce que
maintenant ça y est c je vais dire
derrière nous j'espère que le gros de la
crise est derrière nous enfin bon début
en tout cas du grand débat national qui
plante s'agrandissent la cei aboutira
concertation quoi sur quelle fiscalité
sur quels jeux call projet moi j'ai un
peu d'allant prononcer quand je connais
pas beaucoup les cartes et que je
connais pas la direction qui suivit bon
d'autres éléments le break site
aujourd'hui il ya des incertitudes
autour du brics its assez inquiète aussi
les chefs d'entreprise j'ai l'impression
que les enviais déjà eux-mêmes ne savent
pas trop ce qu'ils veulent faire je
lisais ce matin dans la presse que qu'on
voulait rappeler churchill
que vont faire les anglais qui vous fait
il qu'elle sera la véritable incidence
du principe une grosse crainte du coup
sur le commerce international ont raté
leur site
aujourd'hui
les prochains jours le diront ne sais
pas en tout cas il ya effectivement des
incertitudes autour de ce bris site
inquiétude aussi des chefs d'entreprise
sur un autre sujet celui du prélèvement
à la source qui a été mise en place au
1er janvier les premières fiches de paye
vont arriver fin janvier il ya quatre
entreprises sur dix qui se disait un
certaine d'être prête au 1er janvier
c'est toujours un motif d'un kilo et
inquiétude c il faut faire la part des
choses ça c'est plutôt technique c'est
pas quelque chose qui va toucher à la
croyance qu'il a touché l investissement
par contre il est vrai que alors pour
les grands groupes je dirais ils ont une
certaine taille le problème est
relativement bien traité
il n'en demeure pas moins que pour les
petites et très petites entreprises qui
ont qui ont moins de facilités
ça reste quelque chose de compliqué
d'insurmontable mais compliqué et ce qui
nous inquiète c'est moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est la façon dont vont le
recevoir nos salariés
aujourd'hui de salariés accomplissant le
même emploi ayant la même tâche recevait
un salaire équivalent ils ont toujours
d'ailleurs ce même salaire la grande
différence c'est que leurs feuilles de
paye ne sera pas la même et comment ceux
là veulent qui est perçue par nos
salariés s'agit pas de réponse à vous
donner et c'est plutôt sur le climat
social est ce que ça peut engendrer dans
l'entreprise en termes de climat que
nous avons inquiétudes s'il y en a une
et on verra la suite dans les prochains
mois sur les difficultés rencontrées par
les entrepreneurs y vino vous parliez
tout à l'heure du recrutement qui se
fait sur la longue durée ils ont des
difficultés à trouver leurs salariés les
entrepreneurs imminent vous savez c'est
un paradoxe c'est un paradoxe
j'entends autour de moi et même moi même
j'ai combats souvent du mal à recruter
je pense que c'est
alors il ya effectivement pour certains
qui enregistrait pointu de nouvelles
technologiques des pommes de formation
de trouver le profil adéquat a pas de
formation
et dans une un des postes les plus les
plus larges que la base des employés qui
sont les postes qui ne demandent pas de
qualification et qui sont donc forcément
les moins rémunérés puisqu'ils londres
reculent qualifications aujourd'hui
existe un phénomène qui fait que le le
coup le travail le bénéfice du travail
n'est pas assez récompensés aujourd'hui
et je pense qu'on a vraiment un vrai
problème savez j'avais un jour un autre
débat jacques il disait
l'état est un de nos concurrents est un
de nos concurrents dans le monde du
travail parce que si on devrait y voir
suffisamment le travail par rapport à la
non activité bah on peut avoir jeté
problèmes que nous rencontrons qu'on a
compris des inquiétudes et aussi des
difficultés merci bertrand de créer
d'avoir été sur ce plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes le président du medef
yvelines où on aura l'occasion de
dresser des bilans et ce sera dans les
prochains mois avec les heures faire
expertiser ses bijoux les versaillais en
avaient la possibilité ce jeudi tableau
ou autres trésors que l'on se transmet
de génération en génération une journée
gratuite dédiée était organisée
aujourd'hui à versailles aurélie rose
l'a suivi
donner une valeur et une opinion sur
l'authenticité d'un bijou d'un tableau
bien d'un objet d'art voici le principe
de cette journée d' expertise gratuite
exceptionnellement canaliser ce jeudi 17
janvier à versailles sommes une maison
de vente aux enchères donc on
organise des journées des expertises et
des ventes aux enchères à la fois à lyon
dans notre hôtel des ventes et à paris
les expertises se font dans nos bureaux
dans le 6e et les vente à l'hôtel drouot
cette marée noire entre semaine
j'avais quelques objets de
l'ange ignorait la valeur
je voulais préciser les choses dans ses
peurs pour leur régler des successions
pour l'est les partages à mes enfants
succession inventaire pour assurance ou
gestion d'une collection d'art les
raisons sont multiples pour venir faire
estimer son objet gilone a apporté des
bijoux appartenant à ses ancêtres des
broches un portable selon elle et qui
l'encombré j'ai une estimation pour
chaque chaque pièce et on verra on verra
si c'est sa part apple sommes fouilles
dans les 500 euros chaque objet oui à
peu près
oui je ne serais même pas tant vous
voyez pas ce que cherche des bijoutiers
ont proposé rien du tout les bijoux de
givonne seront vendues aux enchères le
20 février prochain à paris c'est un
patrimoine datant du xviie siècle érigée
dans la vallée de chevreuse par jules
hardouin mansart le parc est attribuée à
andré le nôtre le château de dampierre
en yvelines a depuis le 1er janvier un
nouveau directeur général c'est vous
parce qu'elle tait baron soir merci
d'être avec nous alors vous avez été
nommé par franky mulliez qui est
propriétaire des lieux depuis l'été
dernier vous étiez auparavant le
directeur des bâtiments et jardins au
domaine national du château de chambord
alors pour présenter déjà le château de
dampierre il a été achevé en 783
propriété pendant de longues années des
duc de luynes et des royaux ont
également séjourné qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait un patrimoine intéressant dampierre
c'est une pépite au sein de la vallée de
chevreuse à proximité du château de
versailles
dampierre c'est un peu la résidence
secondaire des rois on sait que louis
xiii avait de forts liens avec le duc de
luynes on sait que louis xiv par colbert
a permis la construction du château
dampierre que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et dampierre c'était aussi
la résidence secondaire de marie lésine
ce cas la femme de l'oukase qui avait
horreur de la cour à versailles et louis
15 est venu aussi à dampierre pour
festoyer patrimoine dont il y avait une
longue histoire peut être aujourd'hui
méconnu car il est fermé en tout cas au
public depuis 2016 il mérite d'être de
nouveau dans la lumière ce patrimoine
parce ce patrimoine mérite évidemment
puisqu'il s'inscrit dans l'histoire de
la france il s'inscrit dans l'histoire
de l'architecturé dans l'histoire de
l'art l'histoire de l'art des jardins
tout un patrimoine qui fait 400 hectares
avec cette pépite au milieu tout ça avec
de l'eau fin on a vraiment un fort
potentiel
d'attraction est fermé depuis 2016 au
public donc c'était un peu la belle
endormie et franky mulliez quand il m'a
appelé
voulu savoir si j'étais partant pour
réveiller cette belle endormie et
développer une activité touristique pour
montrer cette oeuvre à tous vous l'étiez
un réel potentiel à dampierre il ya un
vrai potentiel latent pierre sait déjà
il avait le chevreuil avec toute sa
fréquentation enfin tous les gens se
coller à la grille je suis très surpris
de cette attractivité de ce site on voit
les gens s'arrêter en bord de route
prendre des photos ils n'attendent
qu'une chose et qui la grille est
ouverte c'est de rentrer en leur dit non
pas encore bientôt mais d'ailleurs
pourquoi avoir quitté le confort de
chambord où la réputation du château
n'est n'est plus à faire pour venir ici
dans les yvelines et et repartir
quasiment à zéro avec un projet à zéro
parce que c'était un vrai challenge jeu
c'est vrai pourquoi j'ai quitté chambord
chant port j'y suis arrivé au moment où
il ya les créations d'établissements
publics du domaine national de chambord
et donc du coup il y avait tout à faire
j'y suis arrivé en 2006 je vais l'équité
début 2019
treize années où treize années de
chantier qui ont permis de remettre à
niveau le domaine de chambord en tenant
compte de tous les paramètres aussi bien
touristique patrimoniaux économique et
donc du coup fort de cette aventure fort
de cette expérience je souhaitais
quitter chambord parce que ça fait
treize années que j'y étais et que
l'année 2010 9 h voire est importante
mais parce que c'est de sa centième de
la fondation mais je n'avais plus rien à
y faire puisque les plus importants
avaient été réalisés et donc du coup je
souhaitais mettre la profite maintenant
dans ma carrière dans mon aventure
professionnelle et bien auprès d'un
autre joyau du patrimoine national et
dampierre fait partie et justement on
imagine que cette expérience acquise à
chambord va vous servir dans cette
nouvelle mission complètement
complètement c'est chambord était un cas
particulier puisque c'est un
établissement public de l'état même si
tous les agences ne sont pas
fonctionnaires on est aux deux contrats
de droit privé mais on travaille pour
l'état pour valoriser un bien national
eh bien à dampierre c'est un domaine
privé détenu par franky mulliez le
fondateur de kiloutou et qui lui
mérite autant d'attention que chambord
dampierre pour moi c'est un niveau de
patrimoine aussi élevé que fontainebleau
vaux-le-vicomte face et des monuments
qui mérite toute l'attention et parce
qu'ils ont été oubliés et bien on sait
que derrière il ya un potentiel de
développement est une vallée de
chevreuse attractive qui va aussi
permettre dans le territoire de tirer
vers le oui de créer une vallée
touristiques et des biens sur un projet
pour faire rayonner de nouveau ce
domaine ça est annoncée vous fixé comme
objectif de rouvrir le parc du château à
partir du 30 mars c'est la première
étape la première étape c'est ouverture
du parc le 30 mars en effet oui on sait
on relève les deux beaux défis à
dampierre il faut créer un parc de
stationnement il faut créer une
billetterie faut créer une boutique un
point snack à sa non tf1 etc et créer
des animations donc au 30 mars on ouvre
au 30 mars on ouvre d'ici là où l'art à
requalifier les jardins qu'on attribue à
le nôtre on a requalifié un jardin
anglais ce qui tombe a peur des études
et puis on a concret aux six une
animation première animation c'est la
balade en attelage en calèche qui sera
compris dans le forfait de des voeux du
tourisme où on découvrira non seulement
les abords du château mais également le
parc animalier avec les daims les
sangliers qui sont la proximité des
calèches réouverture ce qu'a fait
réalisable il reste beaucoup de travaux
d s'il reste des travaux mais si l'on se
donne pas de deux objectifs je n'y
arrivera pas ça c'est la première étape
et ensuite au fur et à mesure des années
de nouveau
espace qui s'ouvriront avec l'objectif
final c'est l'ouverture du château mais
il y a deux à trois ans de chantier
parce qu'il faut non seulement refaire
les travaux qui sont nécessaires mais
aussi remettre au niveau pour pouvoir
accepter
d'accueillir les connexions de franky
mulliez qui est passionné d'oeuvre d'art
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il a choisi
dans pierre c'était pour dans ce château
du 16e montrer ses collections d'oeuvres
d'art du xviie siècle qu'est ce qu'on
pourra y voir dans ce pas vous disiez
des animations on parlait alors de tout
à l'heure de jardin attribua le nôtre
c'est des jardins à la française jardin
à l'anglais zfi gèrent bien leur jardin
à la française pour le nôtre au fond du
parc c'est une création plutôt des
années 70 s'est fait par un hollandais
non peuls heureux qualifiés pour
redonner un sens à l aménagement
paysager globale et donc du coup on sera
plutôt sur un jardin à l'anglais c'est
comme ça que l'on en tout cas je les
définit
ce qu'on y voit ses cd c'est un état a
aujourd'hui avant travaux puisque lille
va il y à une équipe de maîtrise
d'oeuvre qui réfléchit actuellement qui
étudie la restitution de ce que pourrait
être fin de ce que sera dans pierre
depuis aparté des archives pour redonner
du lustre à tout cet ensemble donc du
coup le jardin aujourd'hui on replante
des topiaires en requalifier les espaces
on aménage un peu d'aires de pique nique
un peu d'herbe de jeux pour les enfants
traînent dans l'esprit ten attraits
naturels on est ainsi classé on est
aussi monuments historiques donc il faut
respecter les lieux et puis un lieu
comme suit de dampierre évidemment le
mérite tout respect et donc on va
valoriser en montrant tous ces aspects
là et en développant s'il est un peu de
canotage sur le plan d'eau la grande
pièce d'où fait sept hectares et demi et
donc on peut y faire du bateau comme
offrant comme pas françois premier
pardon comme louis 15 le faisait
d'ailleurs question on vous l'avait dit
le projet final c'est de restaurer
complètement ce château ça va prendre
combien de temps alors le fil en fait
c'est un projet beaucoup plus globale
puisque le domaine c'est un projet
domaniale il ya non seulement le château
il ya les communs où on va exposer
d'ailleurs les quelques carrosse du duc
de luynes qui nous ont laissés donc on
va les exposés de la dea d'ouverture
c'est plusieurs bâtiments où il ya des
collections de
de curieux la cabine et curiosité et
d'autres espaces qui vont être réouvert
donc c'est plusieurs années de travaux
qui va secret que concrétiser au final
par la construction d'une école
d'attelage on va finaliser l'ensemble
par une école d'attelage franky mulliez
passionnés de d'attelage qui répare ni
mules et donc on va faire une une des
rares et peut-être la seule école
d'attelage en france qui sera installée
donc à dampierre qui jouxtera un musée
des carrosses de dampierre puisque
franky mulliez a investi dans 25
carrosse de collection l'histoire
historique et qui mérite une
conservation très particulière et ça
sera la cerise sur le gâteau à la fin de
ces quatre ans de travaux et donc
première date à retenir le 30 mars avec
la réouverture de ce parc du château de
dampierre en yvelines merci hamas
restait là d'être passé sur ce plateau
directeur général du château à de
dampierre tout de suite le retour du
portrait de la rédaction
[Musique]
il a été l'un des joueurs majeurs du
club de basket de trappes au début des
années 2000 bamba cei est de retour dans
les yvelines l'été dernier l'ancienne
star trappistes assigné au chesnay
versailles rencontre signé michael et
demi d'euros
il fait son come back dans les yvelines
le basketteur bamba cei 39 ans a rejoint
les rangs du chesnay versailles l'été
dernier après avoir joué avant nationale
2 son objectif relever un dernier défi
avec le club de r avant de raccrocher
ses baskets
je me suis dit que je vais venir à
versailles pour essayer de c'est d'aider
l'équipe à remonter parce qu'ils ont
très très bon projet que je voulais à
berrer au futur c'est plus qu'une plus
value ses
limites au miracle que dizaine qui vient
de jouer avec nous étant donné qu'il
était encore l'année dernière en
national de quoi avant de signer au
chesnay versailles bamba cei a connu une
carrière riche international sénégalais
avec une quinzaine de sélection jo a
également marqué l'histoire d'un autre
club yvelinois situe à moins de 15
kilomètres le fc trappes saint quentin
en yvelines le numéro 11 a rejoint la
structure en 2002 à l'âge de 22 ans
une équipe familiale et que tout le
monde on s'entre aider les dirigeants
les joueurs tout le monde donc en fait
c'est
le franco-sénégalais d'un mètre
quatre-vingt dix-huit réussir à emmener
le club trappistes en nationale une
grâce à des prestations de haute volée
basketteurs restera au total sept ans
dans la structure malgré les
sollicitations
qui est un peu fidèle je pouvais aller
jouer au dessus et je pouvais aller
tenter ma chance ailleurs
mais je voulais grandir avec mais qui me
frappe est ce qu on a fait un super
nationale une aujourd'hui à presque 40
ans l'intérieur veut avant tout prendre
du plaisir sur les parquets et partager
son expérience avec ses coéquipiers du
chesnay versailles bamba s'improvise
même parfois entraîneur adjoint quand il
le faut mais je sors pas et de suivi et
reprend l'écran je peux pas m'empêcher
sûr mais si je vois des trucs je suis
obligé de
de parler nous donner vacances et
je pense qu'il veut comme il le fait de
manière très respectueuse et il essaie
de rester toujours à sa place donc on en
a beaucoup discuté et c'est même moi qui
l'incitent à 20 me voir et ne pas
hésiter à donner des conseils si besoin
bamba cei voudrait continuer à
transmettre son savoir après sa carrière
en entraînant des genoux en réalisant
des camps de basket caritatif avec son
association sauf hadji au sénégal mais
avant tout il veut continuer à jouer
pour emmener le chesnay-versailles le
plus haut possible
avant de se quitter la lanterne de
rambouillet a accueilli ces petites
briques en bois célèbre jusqu'au 26
janvier le monde en cap la présente des
monuments emblématiques européens et
nationaux patrick jacques de dixmude et
marylène iapichino se sont amusés à les
reconnaître
[Musique]
le london bridge anglais la porte de
brandebourg allemande et même la mairie
de rambouillet la ressemblance est
frappante et impressionne les visiteurs
[Musique]
c'était vraiment très rigolo c'est de
voir les la réaction des gens quand ils
passent la porte ils font tous la même
chose c'est-à-dire ils ont des yeux
vraiment écarquillés et c'est vrai que
c'est impressionnant pour tout le monde
de voir ce qu'ils ont réussi à faire
la lanterne souhaitait une exposition
ludique et interactive
elle a été séduite par la proposition du
centre cap là l'exposition a été montée
à l'aide des scolaires de la ville et
s'est ouverte le 5 décembre un vrai
succès environ 300 visiteurs se rendent
au pôle culturel chaque s'est dit
impressionné par la tour de pise est pas
mal comment elle tient quoi le fait de
quelques chaînes sans colle aussi
ou plus de la visite les enfants peuvent
s'essayer à leur propre construction
avec des ateliers gratuits animés par
des membres du centre cap là
c'est bien il respecte bien et des fois
ça un peu dur mais j'arrive bien au vu
du succès du monde en cap là la lanterne
recherche déjà une nouvelle exposition
pour sa saison 2010 9020 au mois une
exposition dans le style ça peut être un
style artistique différent mais ce que
je veux dire c'est avec un objectif de
participation de la population et
et vraiment un objectif de rassembler
les différents âges en fête et notamment
les enfants et les jeunes vous avez
jusqu'au 26 janvier pour reconnaître la
sagrada familia de barcelone et encore
le port de copenhague
est plus il est sorti dans le à 7,8
loisirs de marylène iapichino c'est la
fin de ce journal avant de vous laisser
à cette information vigilance sur les
routes
cette nuit et demain matin des
températures négatives sont annoncées
possiblement avec du gel sur les axes
saint-quentin-en-yvelines prévoit cette
nuit l'intervention de ces engins de
salage à partir de 3h30 sur les routes
inter départementale soyez donc prudents
belle soirée avec télé 78
[Musique]